you know he will focus and come back
even more determined we never see Magnus
Carlson well I shouldn't say that we
rarely see Magnus Carlson crumble
absolutely and here we go the game has
started yeah and so far early days but
it's a variation of the Queen's Gambit
declined
I'll accept it that way yes so that is
all about whether black captured earlier
a Pawn on the C4 square but he declined
to take that pawn and now by trading off
here okay we're going to the tarash
defense
uh this is maybe a bit rare nowadays at
the top level uh black taking that pawn
there is something they call the uh what
is it yeah he stopped level of running
much earlier than he did in the previous
game okay he trades off for the Black
Knight and he really opens things up
aggression early aggression tell us what
is the most common in this position well
both moves are equally viable and uh
this one is has been played before
um the top game there is actually by par
Iranian Grandmaster param maxudlu but I
mean there were previous lines where
they went to the right okay instead live
on okay this decision looks a bit odd
yes he grabs a pawn but he allows this
bishop to develop with Tempo I'm
assuming Magnus will capture this Knight
and uh after the Knight is traded off at
least now it's much much quicker for
black to Castle so you've kind of helped
your opponent speed up their development
white is temporarily a pawn up okay
Magnus does go for this trade I'm not
sure whether you Castle first you could
go for a check hitting the white king
and then just win your Pawn back if you
want to play safe
I think Levon aronian because he won the
last game he just wants to get to Safety
in this one and in game two against Liam
Lair the bar is all the way over to
Liam's side whilst the players are
having a thing okay David over to you
sir
oh I'm not sure whether it's bold at
this point but I'll say a teenager is
going to win the tournament oh nice one
I've got five and eight chance oh
wait really wow and okay
um so the computer we see the top stock
fish moves it confirms black has a
winning move it's not King C8 which the
computer says it means castling Queen
side so the black king is going to
Castle Queen side we said it was too
risky earlier but now it just wins has
he forgotten this is legal I'm trying to
work out why as well Kaya I guess it
just creates a deadly pin and if we jump
into the game right now uh we have to
investigate actually there's two strong
moves even giving a check with the queen
which is also natural that gives black
an advantage castle and queen side wins
on the spot
it is quite natural what do you think
Simon yeah yeah I mean that well it's it
is very natural The Rook The Rook comes
into play uh it pins the bishop you get
the other Rook ready to come in as well
that might be a key thing I mean it
looks so obvious uh to to play this move
and uh I I is Magnus gonna play it I
mean I think he's spotted it 100 I
reckon 100 I think he's seen it up for
sure definitely he's looking at and uh
well I mean it's such an obvious move do
you reckon Lev forgot that uh so I think
so because somehow other you know it
wasn't possible and he plays it and uh
it's looking yeah very bad take a look
at level now will he realize because why
on Earth did he then move his Bishop if
it was that bad exactly this is the
problem we're playing so quickly right I
mean uh Lev Lev has banged out his moves
uh again in a position without too much
thought he has castled here
um you were just showing the Slime David
I I don't think that's gonna save the
piece as it doesn't look too difficult
as well it's kind of which piece is
pinned is this bishop so just come and
attack it that just wins immediately
maybe the stronger moves I mean maybe
you could attack it with your Bishop as
well the cowboy hat yeah yeah that's a
same actor who played in Love Actually
yeah that's what the kids he kind of
Love Actually yeah and someone told me
that I was like oh wow Game of Thrones
yeah oh yeah yeah and uh meanwhile black
has won a piece Magnus is winning this
position the White Queen has gone on a
little Adventure she's won a pawn in the
process
looks like she can give one check to the
black king but the black king will just
move very safely and
the problem is white has no backup white
has no second attacking piece X Bishop
is actually it's not just any Bishop
it's a monster
you guys pointed out this is actually a
killer threat as well Bishop takes
Knight ruining the white porn structure
uh with that in mind the White Knight
had to run away and it stepped back but
now I mean if you want you could trade
off the knights you don't have to it
feels like the white king is actually in
more danger than black king just because
there's more pieces around it but how
does Magnus deliver The Knockout blow
I'll just see
the coup de gras as they say go out at
the end of the game uh yeah to finish
things off but Magnus he's doing the
right thing again he's done the hard
work one a piece and okay he retreats
could be a massive round of comebacks
miners who lost in the first round to
Levon now with the black pieces it looks
like he's gonna win this one okay I grab
Masters
you know what I honestly don't know
is it all right Chase yeah one person
who's coached me at an event said to get
your opponent's point of view actually
if you stand up and you go and look
around from the other side of the board
so you're always looking at from your
own point of view maybe if you're a
really optimistic player you're looking
at like from the white side but there's
a lot of moves in the game but I don't
think much has really happened but if
you just stand up and walk around so
suddenly you're looking at the board
from your opponent's view you can get a
different kind of perspective on what's
going on so that's something you could
try I I don't do that myself I tried it
and just found it really annoying but
you might want to give it a go um any
other little tips David yeah I mean a
few things I agree just getting up
whether you look at it from your point
point of view or not sometimes if you
get up kind of Splash water on your face
have a snack have a drink then come back
you see things differently or you see
something that wasn't previously there
just take your mind off the board for a
couple of seconds
a couple of minutes another thing that
I've learned from commentating uh
previously my mind was just a jumble it
was just variation variation variation
it still is sometimes but I like to kind
of take a step back and just think okay
what would I do if I was commentating on
this position and actually that gives me
another perspective I feel that's helped
my kind of longer chest my classical
chess so you need to make sure you take
breaks in Rapid chess you want to
concentrate most of the time but uh you
need to pace yourself
meanwhile black is two pieces up on the
board like these guys say you know you
know objectively you're lost but you're
just winging it you're just freestyling
and you know okay fine enjoy it and uh
Magnus doing great things because when
your king is in trouble we've always
said time and time again try and stop
off Queens
The Rook Hut has cut
this doesn't look happy
and okay he takes the Queens off the
board the risk is removed but maybe not
as winning as he was it's only a night
for two pawns now he's still winning of
course still winning I mean I kind of
like what he's I mean if he can just uh
negotiate this little bit of Mayhem
that's happening here there is still a
bit of Mayhem and Lev's doing a great
job of uh just causing that Mayhem then
obviously the piece will win the game
and it's often a good idea to give back
material to to get you know calm down
your opponent's initiative and how can
Lev do anything here to to confuse
Magnus and he's got okay
he's got this move I like that move so
you don't get pinned and you just got to
mop up those pawns slowly and I think it
looks pretty pretty easy now to be
honest why didn't he just uh take the
pawn what am I not seeing I think that
was a good move as well Kaya um but he
wants to keep the black king as safe as
possible and this white Pawn is not
running away anytime soon so maybe he'll
even use the black rook and go and
capture that pawn and the black king is
entirely safe from the white Rook uh or
the white two white Rooks that was the
only hope for Levon saffin Cheto or
fianchetto Brook you know it's a very
good piece you know if you can get that
in front of your king and well okay
magda's just centralizing at the moment
you know now that this has become
Simon's catchphrase amongst other things
you know we should kind of immortalize
it in the chess 24 Play Zone and every
time you hit resign just resign just
resign yeah you know Simon comes up well
done you've resigned yeah people will be
so annoyed you know because it's
horrible to resign anyway and if you've
got my face coming up and no that's not
good it's not a good idea or maybe if
you're playing and then you ask the
computer for tips and the computer's
like yeah you're done
but I like the idea of having a t-shirt
that just says it's time to resign and
like you have your jumper on yeah you're
playing someone and as the position gets
pretty good you're like you just take
the jumper off and it just says time to
resolve oh I like it I like that yeah I
like that I'm gonna yeah so sadistic
yeah just resign now I want to be
playing this game I've met a lot of
strange people in the Chess World
um definitely I can't remember any
who've made it clear you know they're
like you know like this kind of thing
but um I don't know I probably have done
though I would have thought so yeah I
don't know
um so he doubt played me he had a
winning position my king was in the
middle of the board about to get
checkmated and he was just kind of
sitting there like like okay and then he
played it one last move and then I
resigned instantly I didn't even look at
what the move was and only after the
game did I realize that he'd blundered
and I I wasn't kind of drawing or
anything again I was still kind of worse
but I was no longer losing and I could
have fought on like given some serious
uh fighting chances so it was just the
body language I just given up mentally
and uh I mean that's no fault of his he
didn't realize it was a kind of a
mistake either but yeah I shouldn't have
trusted the opponent oh that's why you
gotta focus on the board
absolutely all he needs to do is trade
off the remaining set of Rooks and
Black's extra Knight will tell ah must
be so annoying before I live on getting
a win against the world champion Magnus
in the first game that is not an easy
thing to do but then coming in game two
white pieces oh and it looks like it's
going to be a loss he has to start from
scratch two games to go in the rapid
portion to win the match
that's a black day in this matchup at
least also the matchup between Liam Lee
and Hans Neiman it looks like a day to
be black like winning uh all of the
games in those matches so far so yeah
I'm gonna go and invent the Unicorn
opening next some other fixtures so I
have a hippo then
[Music]
controversial I mean it's a very easy
and nice open to play so it's quite a
lot of positives like any opening does
really he's got to be careful he doesn't
lose too many pawns but he's got enough
and he'd be winning another one very
shortly so it's just a matter of time
but there's so many arguments I see sort
of online about that opening's rubbish
and players who say that are generally
quite low rated they say you can't play
that opening it's rubbish and it doesn't
matter that much yeah
um so is Magna still cruising here I
think so he's just one upon the Black
Knight cannot be captured because it's
discovered check the black Rook suddenly
attacking the white king so the white
King has to move and work on those end
games and Lavon had to step the king
down that was the only way he could
maintain his threat against the F7 Pawn
otherwise the Knight would have given a
check
oh no not not a check but trying to
check and the other way would also walk
into uh obscure right yeah the Knight
coming in and if you take this Pawn then
okay another night Fork then I could
come along or you could skewer the white
king and Rook there's all sorts of
Tricks because black has two pieces
white only has one and if we catch up
with the game position we might be
seeing levonaroni and resign any second
this is a check and when the king moves
the Black Knight is going to go park
itself in the middle of the board
defending this Pawn which defends the
spawn which defends the spawn and uh you
cannot get rid of this formation Magnus
is simply winning he can defend his
Knight with his Rook when he wants this
Pawn will drop and uh it's game over too
much material
okay I live on trying one final trick
the king moves now black can just defend
his Knight with his Rook
suppose you can attack you can move the
Knight if you really want to be flash
but this is safe yeah just get the get
the Box on and this is flashy Simon
attacking The Rook takes pawn and
another skewer check and you win The
Rook but uh yeah Magnus just doing it
the uh the simple way
on just keeping the spawn alive but it's
going nowhere
you can see how determined level one is
today though obviously the way he's
playing
um he's he's he's really this is a good
sign for him you know after him
struggling a bit in the qualifiers is
going to be equal after this game I
think unless something tremendously
strange happens
to Magnus yeah I yeah with five minutes
on the clock yeah I haven't ever seen
Magnus through something like this not
since he was like five years old or
saying even then he was probably losing
the pram yeah yeah throwing Rooks out
the door here you go have a rook so that
extra Black Knight it's it's found loads
of uh kind of safe squares outposts and
that's the key if you can keep it on a
safe Square you will win I think the
Rooks kind of come and take that last
Pawn now it's it's one simple there's
many many ways you can win this but okay
Lev's trying but you can take that white
porn now yeah bring the black Rook back
if you want to play safe you give a
check first yeah maybe the king can
snake its way to the right stale mate
stale Matrix if you take the pawn oh
that's true
have a Checkmate the white king trapped
yeah nice check mate oh we rarely see
that in chess this is a comeback bye
Magnus Carlsen the vulneronian he uh
loses game two